as we take our next call 6 1 7 8 3 0 47
50 let's make sure I'm finding the calls
callers to be a little lopat let's see
if we can bump them up I don't want to
miss a word of what our next caller says
name and where you're calling from hello
yes you're on the air you're where are
you calling on what's your name my name
is Orlando great what's on your mind
today well here's the thing what's one
thing that surround himself with people
about conspiracy conspiracy and always
not true they always seem to hype things
up and get away with this well I mean
the tone was set from the very very
beginning Orlando that Trump had said
whatever he wants doesn't matter if it's
true and he's not going to lose support
Trump lied he didn't lose support Trump
lied constantly Trump said he could
shoot people on Fifth Avenue and his
supporters wouldn't be dissuaded so when
there's no repercussions for just making
stuff up why would you stop doing it if
it's politically advantageous right I
mean it's been working for the guy to do
if they are you talking you're talking
about the are you talking about the
email stuff and classified documents
involving David various yeah yeah I mean
it's different because David Petraeus
was a patriotic general and Hillary
Clinton is you know an unpatriotic
Democrat from New York or whatever a
very very good point well made I really
appreciate the call Orlando we are going
to move on